I'm joined today by dr. Jordan B
Peterson who is professor of psychology
at the University of Toronto in Canada
as well as a clinical psychologist he's
catalyzed I I guess what I'm calling uh
professor both support and opposition
because of your reaction to uh what
really two things a bill in Canada
called c16 which would amend the
Canadian Human Rights code in Criminal
Code to add gender identity and
expression and its impact uh directly
and indirectly I guess with regard to
how you would address students in some
of your classes so that that's the way
that I sort of understand the
controversy but I'll allow you to sort
of present how this started and what
your position is well it started when I
looked into some of the new legislation
that the federal government was
considering passing similar to
legislation that already exists
provincially in a number of provinces in
Canada and it purports only to add
gender identity and gender I can't
remember the other one gender expression
yet either to the code and but it's
going to be interpreted in the context
of other policies that have been created
by the Ontario Human Rights Commission
for example and there's a couple of
problems with those in my estimation and
the first is is that there's an
insistence in the law of a technical
separation between biological sex gender
identity gender expression and sexual
preference and that's that's a
hypothesis that you might consider a
social constructionist hypothesis it's
based on the idea that there's no
biological basis to let's say gender
identity not speaking about gender
expression is actually more like fashion
it's the manner in which you choose to
present yourself in public with your
your hair and your your makeup and your
clothing and so forth and so
a protected group now as well although I
fail to see how gender expression
constitutes a group at all but anyways
back to gender identity yeah well I
don't think it's true that gender
identity and biological sex are
independent in the way that the social
constructionist insist they believe that
everything that distinguishes men and
women is a consequence of socialization
and nothing else and the fact that
that's now written into the law I think
is very dangerous because it does things
and this has already happened at the
University of Oregon it does things like
call into question even the legality of
presenting biological information that
bears on differences between men and
women and then the other probe and I
think that's a very big problem because
I think that the law is technically
incorrect there is a very tight linkage
in most cases between biological sex and
gender identity given that transgender
identity is very rare perhaps one person
in 300 so for the vast majority of
people their gender identity and their
biological sex are identical and so I
fail to see how that constitutes
independence so and then the next
problem as far as I can tell is that
this is the first example that I've seen
in Canadian law of what you might
describe as compelled speech and so it's
possible to argue that certain forms of
speech should be limited in a free
country although I think you have to be
very careful about that
I mean various countries including
Canada have hate speech legislation
you're in the u.s. I believe yet correct
yes well in the u.s. there's much
tighter protection for freedom of speech
but let's assume for a moment that some
limitations could arguably be placed on
what you can't
so to regulate what you can't say but
this is the first law that I've that I
know of that actually forces you to use
a particular terminology that's now
government approved and you may or may
not know that there is a very large
thora of so-called gender-neutral
pronouns that have been devised there's
no uh there's no consensus on what those
should be yeah let's pause there because
there there's sort of a lot there and
what I think we because there's been so
much controversy generated by your
reaction to this and and I've seen you
know a number of interviews that we've
that you've done about this I'd like to
take the approach of maybe starting to
rule out what some of your concerns are
because some of the the criticisms of
you have been along the lines of well
Jordan Peterson is just transphobic for
example or Jordan Peterson is against
the non-existent problem of political
correctness and that's really the the
angle that he's coming at this from so
let's see if we can just start ruling
out what some of the issues may be with
regard to transphobia you said that that
one in 300 was the number you cited in
terms of the the prevalence of of of
transgender uh do you consider yourself
someone who believes in any other area
that discrimination against someone who
identifies as transgender for example a
business refusing service to someone on
the basis of being transgender it is
anything like that okay in your mind no
it's not okay so with regard to the the
issues I'm sorry go ahead yeah well I
think it's complicated for business
owners often to manage the washroom
problem you know when I feel for them
because it isn't always obvious when
someone is indeterminate saying gender
status to determine how that should be
treated especially in relation to the
reactions of other customers so I think
it's difficult for businesspeople often
to determine and then to do what the
right thing might be so but I'm
certainly not in favor of arbitrary
discrimination okay and with regard to
the concept of transsexuality there are
some articles written and I you're free
to cite them if you want I won't because
you may not agree with them and why if
this is just a non-starter why publicize
articles that that may be inaccurate do
you believe that trans sexuality as an
idea a
is either part of a a leftist agenda or
ideologically driven or in any way
created to uh sort of push back against
cisgendered individuals is does any of
that ring ring a bell with your final
accurate I don't think that the
transgender phenomena is a construction
of political correctness because there
have been people who have had difficulty
with their let's say biological sex
identity for a very long period of time
long before political correctness became
an issue so it's not reasonable to
interview the phenomena itself to
political correctness but the idea that
this this the activist
end of this agenda is part of a
political politically correct movement I
think is undeniable it's part of a
broader postmodern movement that is
aimed at questioning every normative I
would say category and I mean I've had
letters from very many transgendered
individuals by the way the classic
transgendered types don't really have a
problem with pronoun use they just
classical pronoun use they just want to
be referred to by the other pronoun so a
male to female transsexual wants to be
referred to as she and a female to male
transsexual wants to be referred to as
he and assuming that I had quite a long
conversation with one such person that's
on my website Jordan Peters and videos
and so people are interested they can
look into that so I'm not attributing
the phenomena itself to political
correctness but I am pointing out that
the use of the transgender population by
a certain type of let's call them
Marxist / postmodern ideologue is part
of a broader ideologically motivated
attempt to deconstruct that's the
technical word normative categories and
what old is what would what would be the
goal of that I guess would be my
question in
what what would be the goal of this
Marxist politically correct movement and
in what way would this specific aspect
of transgenderism sort of be part of
that well I think the stated goal if you
watch them if you will read about post
modernists most of them were French
intellectuals in the 1970s they
transmuted Marxism what once Marxism had
been shown to fail essentially by the
absolute catastrophe say of the Soviet
Union where there were so many millions
of deaths and also the same thing
happened in China right in other places
it became quite obvious particularly to
group of French intellectuals that
included Michele Foucault and Jacques
Derrida for example that Marxism has
constituted which was the working class
say against the ruling class wasn't
going to fly
partly because capitalist countries had
actually managed to increase them were
the living standards of working class
people quite dramatically and so they
performed the slight in hand in the
1970s and shifted the battle from from
economic warfare to identity warfare
assuming that all normative categories
heterosexuality for example classic
gender divisions were power structures
that were designed only to marginalize
people and the aim of deconstructionism
is to replace the center let's say that
the classic normative structure with the
marginalized and it's so it's a very I
would say a subversive in intellectual
movement I don't think there's any
question about that the people who who
are the main thinkers of the movement
regard themselves as seriously
subversive they they don't like Western
civilization they regard it as
oppressive and patriarchal I mean
anytime you hear someone using the word
patriarchy then you can be sure that
they're under the sway of of postmodern
ideas and the more radical
modernists and you see them particularly
in fields like women's studies and all
the ethnic studies groups that have got
disciplines that have been generated
since the late seventies their goals are
quite straightforward they want to read
construct the patriarchy and so the
patriarchy basically means our
civilization as it currently stands
which they regard as irreparably cropped
let me pause there by can only because
we're at the we we have limited time of
course because of because you do have to
get to a class and we're starting to
drift a little bit from from maybe what
uh was the main focus of it let me cut
to the chase as I see it and see what
your thought on this is uh I think that
there's a very good possibility here
that you're presenting the superior
argument with regard to to the c16 bill
in Canada however I'm wondering from a
purely pragmatic perspective whether
you'd not have more support in terms of
your position on c16 if you didn't uh
communicate what and I'll be very
upfront with you in terms of the way I
interpreted and I'm I don't think I'm
the only one I don't mean this as a
criticism but just a sort of as an
analysis of how I see it
so significant level of hostility
towards transgender individuals as a
separate issue from that of of
gender-neutral pronouns I'm wondering
and I'll give you a chance to respond of
course whether if a student requests an
accommodation with regard to a pronoun
even if you don't think that this makes
any sense even if many people don't
think that it makes any sense might not
making some effort to to go forward with
that accommodation put you on much
stronger footing then for your
opposition to c16 and and the sort of of
legislation of this type of language I'm
what thinking out loud I don't know what
you think well I don't know if it would
put me on stronger footing it would
certainly be easier I can tell you that
um it isn't obvious to me that the
appropriate thing to do when you're
compelled to use words that you don't
agree with that the right thing to do is
to go ahead and use them so I regard the
made up
nouns that she ensure and so forth as
part of the Vanguard this postmodern
movement and sure but what in what way
are you hurt by just doing that if it
makes a student more comfortable if it
makes them take more away from the class
because as they see it not as you see it
maybe not as I see it but as they see it
they're being addressed in the way that
they want to be addressed in in what way
is that jeopardizing you or your
teaching or or the material in class for
example well I don't think there's any
evidence that it will make things better
for them it's just a supposition in fact
I think that the demand to be marked out
with the special use of pronouns which
by the way don't change very frequently
during the English length they're very
fixed words I think the demand backed by
law to be marked out in some special way
is not something that's going to make
anyone feel better except they're
perhaps very temporarily and I think
it's a bad medium to long term strategy
but that's your opinion right I mean in
other words if we have the opinion about
that from the person who is actually
making the request and the opinion of
someone who merely is refusing to use it
should we not at least give equal weight
if not more to the opinion again we're
talking about two opinions of the person
directly affected I don't know again I'm
I'm playing devil's advocate I'm not
even saying I agree with these pronouns
well there the issue here is that I
think the danger of using legislated
language especially that's part of a a
philosophical battle let's call it an
intense intellectual battle that's going
on at the university campuses and that
will increasingly flood out into the
into the normative world outside the
campus I think that ceding control over
language to your ideological opponents
let's say is a large mistake I don't I
regard the postmodern philosophy the
radical postmodern philosophy is
something that is exceedingly dangerous
and the Marxism that it's nested inside
which I'm not imagining Derrida for
example stated clearly that his
philosophy was a transmutation of
Marxism that was
nested inside it I think that if you
seed verbal territory to your
ideological opponents then you you lose
and you might say well doesn't matter if
you're hurting someone's feelings and of
course hurting someone's feelings is a
bad thing if you can avoid it but losing
in a very important ideological battle
is a much worse thing and I don't think
that people understand the seriousness
of this battle although they will come
to understand it over the next few years
as it continues to play itself out I
mean part of the reason that the
American election tilted the way it did
was because a relatively small number of
people and their multiple reasons of
course we're tired of politically
correct demands and the problem with the
post modernists is that whenever they
want to make a move forward in their
attempts to undermine the categorical
structure of the patriarchy they always
pick a victim group and to use as a
front so that they can claim that what
they're doing is motivated by compassion
at that and that their enemies are
bigots and and you know horrible people
and I think that that's a absolutely uh
awful way of maneuvering politically
although it's extraordinarily effective
yeah I don't know effective it is I mean
I think in many ways that identity
politics is is increasingly not
effective and I've been hugely critical
in fact of the American left for that
the use of that to the extent that they
do I I just go back to the idea that I
believe your criticism of c16 would be
seen much more favorably if maybe you
appeared less and I know you're saying
you're not actually hostile to
transgender individuals if you appeared
less hostile to transgender titles
through the class you could get that
case but look it's it's a mystery why
what I did attracted so much attention
right because all I did was make two
videos and put them up on my YouTube
site yeah they work particularly well
produced but they produced an absolute
storm of of controversy far more than I
would
ever hoped for and far more than I would
have ever wanted um I believe the reason
that they produced the controversy is
actually because I I took something
that's a universal problem which is this
ideological battle and I made it about
something extraordinarily specific which
was my specific refusal to use these
made-up words and so that's produced
somewhat of the backlash although I've
received at least in terms of the
letters that I've received far more
support and more support to from the
press at least in Canada then then
criticism and in an issue like this
you're going to generate some criticism
and some support and so far mostly what
I've generated is support and it's
conceivable that someone else could have
done a better job of this and it's
conceivable as well that I could have
done a better job of it but I it's it's
an element of conscience for me not to
use these postmodern neo-marxist this
supposed modern neo-marxist language
because I've studied history quite
intently and I understand the dangers
both of post-modernism and of the
marxist philosophy within which it's
based and I've read very much about how
society start to tilt in pathological
directions and one way they start is by
transmutation of language and so there's
always a price to be paid if you stand
up for something because there are
there's proximal consequences and the
proximal consequences are that it
appears that I'm hurting the feelings of
some transgender people although it
isn't really clear to me that that's the
case especially given that I've received
far more letters of support from
transgender people than letters of
criticism yeah it's not self-evident
that the people who are act who are the
activists on behalf of the transgender
population are there are there
appropriate representatives who says
that they're speaking for them it's just
a claim and I don't buy it and so I'll
use their proper names which the Ontario
Human Rights Commissioner agreed was
acceptable
alright I'm dr. Jordan Peterson I know
you have to run I wish we had
more time I would love to have you back
and we can talk about this again in the
future we've been speaking with
professor Jordan B Peterson thanks so
much for talking to me thanks very much
for having me